madame s'il vous plaît faut passer en
caisse et va j'ai payé il ya deux
minutes là je cherchais mon fils
ah bah voilà tu étais où toi ça fait une
heure que je cherche vous êtes contente
je frappe mon fils moi j'aimerais bien
une télé moi j'aimerais une carte bleue
l'oublier c'est pour tes parents ta
fument maintenant à mon avis c'est pas
d'échec trouvaient de dix à chaque fois
j'ai retrouvé leurs jambes les implore
ces domaines
ce que tu appelles une peine si une
pompe à fric qu'est ce que c'est que ça
les roms dans l'immeuble
alors ça c'est ton mari ça ils fouillent
dans les poubelles maintenant à bien
gênant j'aime paris avec un riche
contrat sarkozyste bonjour madame
sinatti hossam il faudrait vraiment
mettre la moquette à la vieille là ça
nous ferait 100 euros de plus j'ai bac
puis si je pose pas de moquette ça ça
vaut 20 mille euros au moins tu dresses
l'aps m
et ça onze mille 800 euros chérie tu
imagines des crous qui jettent à la
poubelle
auxquelles vous serez martin parce qu'au
foot là bas on écouter le morceau d'alex
en un petit peu dérapé après elle est ou
la lampe à calan veut dire essarts
police on se sacrifie pour monsieur
parce que moi jean clamon quoi elle est
morte
ouais bah ça résout pas tout qui ça
madeleine en font ça en fait les piétons
ont fui on est cuit enfin ça nous accuse
direct qui nous accusent de tête aussi
mais qu'est ce que tu fais pourquoi
serais je vais chercher maman quitte à
faire n'importe quoi par tous ensemble
attendez vous allez où madame angèle
vous rentrez co mais non mais elle
rentre pas elle n'aime pas il part avec
roux aurait une blague
on est la risée du quartier de même
hollande on le regarde avec plus de
respect jiwa second encore quand on met
des gosses ont fait pas n'importe quoi
même pour du fric en algérie soit je
préfère passer pour un fou pour un
minable je suis tu vas partir ça fait
très longtemps
c'est noël j'ai un petit peu de pognon
tout et qu'on se marre comme avant dieu
c'est l'honnêteté c'est un concept
inventé par les riches pour que les
pauvres ferment leur gueule
quand j'ai trente joueurs et on perd je
voudrais qu'on l'enterré médiateur très
profonde tu vois dans la terre mais
monsieur le prince par amis chinois
geely